TO THE JUNE THIRTIETH NOW NOW
GEN THIRD ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS SUSPENSE
TERRAIN- DISPENSING OF OUR
ASSEMBLY BILLS. I AM GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND START BY HAVING-
OUR SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. GONZALEZ PRESENT
BIGELOW. MARK I AM BLOOM BONTA
CALDERON CARRILLO CHAO DOLLY
DEEP. EGGMAN. FONG GABRIEL
GARCIA. PETRIE-NORRIS RECORDED
FOR QUIRK RITEISH VOEPEL. ALL
RIGHT I WANT TO REMIND THE
MEMBERS WHO AREN'T HERE THAT-
UNTIL YOU GET HERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY DISPENSE OF SOME OF
THESE BILLS. I THINK WE CAN
ACTUALLY. WE HAVE TEN. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT
NINE NINE. ALL RIGHT I'D ALSO
WE WERE HOPEFUL TODAY. SO WE
HAVE ELEVEN DAMS NOW. ALL RIGHT
I THINK WE CAN DO TO BE ROLL
CALL AS LONG AS WE BRING TYLER
OVER FOR A BI- I'M ALL RIGHT
GOOD AFTERNOON. AGAIN WE WERE
HOPING TO START THIS
APPROPRIATIONS HEARING FIRST BY
HEARING A SENATE BILL SENATE
BILL SIX TWENTY FIVE BY MISTER
BRADFORD IF SOMEBODY HAS SEEN
SENATOR BRADFORD ANYWHERE IN
THE BUILDING. IT BE GREAT IF HE
COULD MAKE IT HERE BECAUSE THAT
WOULD BE THE PREFERRED COURSE
OF ORDER. IF NOT WE MAY GO
AHEAD AND START. I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND GET THROUGH ALL THE
FORMALITIES AND MISTER BRADFORD
NOT HERE WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND START WITH ASSEMBLY BILLS
AND DO OUR ENTIRE DUMP AND THEN
WE WILL GO BACK TO. THE SENATE
BILL. MR BLOOM THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. ALL RIGHT. WELCOME.
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND TURN
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
SUSPENSE FILE BEFORE WE START
WITH THE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT BILLS ON THE SUSPENSE
FILED LIKE TO THINK THE WORK OF
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
REPUBLICAN STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK IT'S MUCH APPRECIATED I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF OF THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE THE ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY PERSONNEL AND THE
MANY OTHERS TO HELP MAKE THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS CONTINUE
DURING THESE VERY HARD TIMES
INCLUDING OUR OPERATOR NICK
YESTERDAY WHO DID A FINE JOB.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THINK MY VICE
CHAIR FRANK BIGELOW- FIRST
COOPERATION AND SUPPORT FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WATCH THESE
BEFORE YOU KNOW HE HELPS ME GET
THROUGH THIS FILE AND WORST
SOCIALLY DISTANCE SO HOPEFULLY
WE I DON'T MAKE TOO MANY
MISTAKES TODAY ALSO ONE HAND
IT'S MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE HARD
WORK IT'S STILL HARD TO READ
ALL THESE BILLS WHEN WE'RE ALL
APART FROM EACH OTHER.
YESTERDAY THE COMMITTEE HEARD
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVEN BILLS
OF THOSE WE MET AT A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY EIGHT TO THE SUSPEND
FILE THOSE REPRESENTED EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE OF OUR
ON GOING FUNDING WE'RE GONNA
HONE DOWN MORE TODAY. IN EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE IN TIME TIMES
WE'D NEVER QUITE A COUPLE PAN
DE GEN IT'S A REST UP
ABBREVIATED TIME WE'RE GONNA
GET THROUGH AS MUCH AS KNOW AND
I REALLY PROUD OF WHAT
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN A. THE BILL
IT'LL PASS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO REFER. PARK VALUE.
DESPITE AN ECONOMIC SESSION
THOUGHT WAS A- TO DO THE HARD
WORK THAT WE BEEN DOING HERE IN
THE STATE. TACKLING HOME. IN
OUR HOUSING SHORTAGE PROTECTING
OUR ENVIRONMENT SEEKING TO
CRACKED. NOT JUST DECADES BUT
CENTURIES OF SYSTEMATIC RACISM
AND INJUSTICE. IN PROTECTING
OUR STATE'S WORKFORCE. AND
WORKERS. IT'S NOW TIME TO
DISPENSE WITH THESE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT BILLS. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THAT THE
HEARING AGENDA IS ORGANIZED
ALPHABETICALLY BY AUTHOR. AND
IS AVAILABLE ONLINE AT THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHICH IS
LOCATED AT EIGHT P. R. O. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA. DOT G. O. V.
LATER THIS AFTERNOON FOLLOWING
TODAY'S HEARINGS THE COMMITTEE
WILL POST THE RESULTS OF THE
SUSPENSE FILE HEARING ON THAT
SAME WEBSITE. MR BECAUSE THERE
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO SHARE
BEFORE WE GET STARTED. WITHOUT
WE WILL BEGIN. THE FIRST BILL
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE IS AB
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT RIGHT
AGUIAR-CURRY. A BILL ON BAGLEY
KEENE. THIS BILL PASSES
COMMITTEE WITH AMENDMENTS TO
REDUCE POSTING TIME TO FORTY
EIGHT HOURS I SEE A MOTION BY
MS CARILLO A SECOND BY MISTER
CALDERON THIS BILL GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL SUBSTITUTE THE MOTION AND
SECOND FOR ALL DO PASS ARE ALL
DO PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS ON
THE REST OF THE SUSPENSE FILE.
AB TWO FORTY SEVEN AGUIAR-CURRY
EMERGENCY PLANNING TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY ONE OH SIX
AGUIAR-CURRY HABITAT INCENTIVE
PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR
AGUIAR-CURRY PROJECT ECHO
PROGRAM HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE ARAMBULA
SMALL TELEPHONE CORPORATIONS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO GIVE THE
CPUC DISCRETION OVER RATE CASE
FORM TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY EIGHT AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY NINE ARAMBULA BLOOD
SCREEN SALES TAX EXEMPTION DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO MAKE IT A
TWO YEAR SUNSET THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. AB THREE THREE
ZERO EIGHT THREE ARAMBULA
AMBULATORY SURGICAL CENTERS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY THREE BARRICADE
HAND COUNTY JAILS RECIDIVISM DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION AND DEFINE
RECIDIVISM THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX
BAUER-KAHAN REMOTE LEARNING DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO STRIKE TAX
PROVISIONS AND INSTEAD REQUIRE
STUDY ON THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT BERMAN BASIC NEEDS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO ENCOURAGE
CAMPUSES TO HAVE CENTERS OF
COORDINATORS AND DELETE THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE REPORT THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY FORTY BIGELOW MADERA
COUNTY RAF TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO ALLOCATE THE PAYMENTS OVER
FIVE YEARS THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLLCALL. AB TWENTY SEVENTY
SIX BIGELOW FIRE PREVENTION AND
STATE PARKS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE THE BILL
IS CONTINGENT UPON A NON
GENERAL FUND BUDGET
APPROPRIATION THAT GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY THREE BLOOM ATERSHED
RESTORATION HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
THIRTY ONE OH SEVEN BLOOM
HOUSING TO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTEEN
BONTA MEDICALLY SUPPORTIVE FOOD
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT BONTA PRIVATE
DETENTION FACILITIES DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO LAMINATE THE DUTIES
OF THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FOUR OH
FIVE BURKE THE RIGHT TO HOUSING
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO MAKE
CONTINGENT UPON THE PREPARATION
THE BUDGET IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY TWENTY SIX YEAR.
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
BURKE CAL WORKS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE THAT GETS THEM
DOESN'T GET OUT HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT BURKE DOMESTIC WORKER
PROTECTIONS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY BURKE
GROUP FILING FOR NON RESIDENT
RETURNS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PROVIDE TO REMOVE PROVISIONS ON
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT BACK IT'S OUT ON A
ROLL CALL AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
CALDERON SECURITIES LAW DO PAT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB.
TWENTY FORTY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT CARILLO
INTERNATIONAL MEDICAL GRADUATES
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
THIRTY FIFTY TWO CARILLO FOR
STERILIZATION. HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY SIX OH SIX
OUR WATER SUPER RELEASE FILE DO
PASS. ON ON A ROLL CALL. AB
SEVEN THIRTY SERVE. TO PLANNING
PASS A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY TWO
SÝ ONE CHILD RECOGNITION TECH
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB TWENTY TWO
H. HEALTH TRACKING SYSTEM
PRIVACY. DO PASS WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CHEN CHINO
HILLS STATE PARK HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY NINE DAVID CHIU NEEDS
AND GAPS ANALYSIS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN DAVID CHIU ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES DO
PASSED WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN CHIU UNSAFE HANDGUNS TO
PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
THIRTY FORTY CHIU HOUSING
CREDITS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTY NINETY SIX DAVID CHIU
YOU SEE AN PER VIOLATIONS DO
PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
THIRTY TO SIXTY NINE DAVID CHIU
HOUSING AND HOMELESS INSPECTOR
GENERAL. DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ADD THE PROVISIONS OF AB TWENTY
THREE TO TWENTY NINE INTO THIS
BILL THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY TWO KANSEN
CHU CHARTER IN PRIVATE SCHOOL
SITES DO PASS WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO CUNNINGHAM TEACHER
CREDENTIALS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY ONE.
MEGAN DOLLY SMALL SCHOOLS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB THIRTY
SIXTEEN MEGHAN DOLLY BORDER
REGISTERED NURSES DO PASS ON
ANY ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN DAILY INSURANCE
MARKET ACTION CLASS. PLAN TO
PASS ON ANY ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY DALY
HOUSEHOLD MOVERS TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB THIRTY FIFTY
THREE DALY ARMIDE WILL ONLINE
WAGE CLAIMS TO PASS AS A
MINUTES DELAY IMPLEMENTATION BY
SIX MONTHS THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EGGMAN HOTEL MOTEL
CONVERSIONS HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE
FRIEDMAN HOUSING FOR FOSTER
USED TO PASS IS AMENDED TO READ
ALLOW REMOTE INSPECTIONS THAT
GETS OUT. ON A ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE
FRIEDMAN CLIMATE SCIENCE
ADVISORY TEAM DO PASSES
AMENDMENT AS AMENDED TO REMOVE.
TO MOVE THE ADVISORY TEAM TO
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. AB THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR
FRIEDMAN AMBER RESISTANT SOUNDS
TO PASS. WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR FRIEDMAN WILDFIRE RISK
MODEL DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE
FRIEDMAN SYKORA. DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ALLOW FOR ALL
ATTORNEYS FEES AND RESTORE
PROVISION OF EXISTING LAW TO
RESTORE THE NINETY DAYS ALLOWED
FOR PETITIONER TO REQUEST A
TRIAL THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. AB THIRTY THREE FIFTY TWO
FRIEDMAN TENET HOUSING
COMPLAINTS TO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT
GABRIEL HOUSING PRESERVATION
TAX CREDIT HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY SIX GABRIEL
PEACE OFFICER TRAINING HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY
ONE GABRIEL UNLAWFUL DETAINER
STEW PASSES AMENDED TO LIVE IN
A COURT CARS COST RELATED TO
DATA COLLECTION THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTEEN GABRIEL
HOMELESSNESS AN ACADEMIC PROP
PROGRESS DO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER
TO PASS ON TO BE. ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX
THAT WAS ABOUT ASSUMPTION AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX GABRIEL
HOMELESSNESS REPORT DO PASSES
AMENDMENT AS AMENDED TO REDUCE
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO CRISTINA
GARCIA HUMAN COMPOSED STEAM. DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ENSURE CD P.
H. CAN RECOVER COSTS SECONDS
HOW THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
AB TWENTY NINENINETY CRISTINA
GARCIA OVERSIGHT OF EDUCATIONAL
ENRICHMENT. DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO PROHIBIT A CHARTER SCHOOL
FROM OFFERING FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES AND LIMIT OTHER
PROVISIONS TO NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS BACK IT'S
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY THREE AT A
GARCIA DME TAX DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
TO JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES. THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY SIX. A GARCIA JOSHUA
TREE NATIONAL PARK HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB THIRTY SEVENTY
NINE EIGHTY GARCIA LIFELINE
PROGRAM HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY AB THIRTY TO FIFTY SIX
EDUARDO GARCIA THE BOND AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ADD AN URGENCY
CLAUSE IN REFER THE BILL TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB THIRTY
THREE OH SEVEN EDUARDO GARCIA
MANUFACTURING LOAN PROGRAM TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE GIPSON WRIST CARE
PILOT TO PASS AMENDED TO ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO RECOVER. LAKE I GET
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY FOUR GIPSON
CORRECTION PERSONNEL HOLDING.
ABC TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE
GIPSON FIRST RESPONDERS
PRIVACY. FIRST RESPONDERS AND
PRIVACY THAT'S A DO PASS WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY NINE GIPSON
GAMBLING LICENSES DO PASSES
MINUTES REMOVE PRESUMPTION OF
STABILITY AND CHANGE LICENSE
RENEWALS PACKETS OUT. ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO
GLORIA PET STORES DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE CRIMINAL
PENALTY AN INSERT INTENT
LANGUAGE RELATED TO A CIVIL
PENALTY BACK IT'S OUT ON A ROLL
CALL AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY GONZALEZ
WORKER CLASSIFICATION TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN GONZALEZ WORKER
CLASSIFICATION DO PASSES
AMENDED TO ADD EMERGENCY CLAUSE
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE
GONZALEZ AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
PASS. ON A ROLL CALL. IF THANK
I'M SORRY I SKIPPED AB TWENTY
NINE SIXTY GIPSON FIRE SAFETY
STANDARDS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. YOU WERE IN THE RIGHT
PLACE I WAS IN THE WRONG PLACE.
ANYONE'S TRACKING AT HOME. MR
BIGELOW ONE. MISS GONZALEZ ZERO.
AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX GONZALEZ
WAREHOUSE DISTRIBUTION CENTERS
DO PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE GONZALEZ
WAGE CLAIM ENFORCEMENT TO PASS
ON A B. ROLL CALL AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR GRAY HORSE RACE
SAFETY DO PASSED WITH TECHNICAL
MEMON SECONDS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
THREE GRAY USE HUNTING PROGRAM
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB THIRTY
FORTY FIVE GRAY PROFESSIONAL
LICENSES DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY GRAYSON
AIR AMBULANCES DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DIRECT PENALTY
REVENUE TO THE GENERAL FUND
BEGINNING JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TO ADD AN
URGENCY CLASS THAT GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL. AB NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR HOLDEN MEDI CAL FOR
INMATES TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY NINETEEN HOLDEN DAHLE
INVOLVEMENT PARTNERSHIPS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR HOLDEN
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
DISABILITIES PROVIDER RATES
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY
SIXTY HOLDEN LEADED DRINKING
WATER TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO DETERMINE
COMPLIANCE CLARIFY DEFINITION
OF LEAD FREE AND CHANGE THE
TERM. AND USE TO END POINTS
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY THIRTEEN IRWIN
REBUILDS PROPERTY DO PASS ON IN
A ROW CALL. A TWENTY OH EIGHT
IRWIN CHARBEL FINERY TO ON TO
BE ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO WHEN GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS TO PASS ON
AND A ROLL CALL. AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTEEN IRWIN MOBILITY DEVICES
DATA HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE JONES
SAWYER CALIFORNIA SCIENCE
CENTER DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE POST TRAINING THAT WE
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN KALRA
RETALIATION PAT CLAIMS TO PASS
ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTEEN KALRA HEALTH PLAN
AND ENSURE REPORTING DO PASS ON
A B. ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY TWO KALRA UNCLAIMED
FUNERAL EXPENSES DO PASS ON AND
BE ROLL CALL NO ON A ROLL CALL.
A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE KALRA ALTERNATIVE
TEACHER CREDENTIALS TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. AB THIRTY THIRTY
KALRA CONSERVATION GOALS DO
PASSED WITH OTHERS AMENDMENTS
TO LINE THE BILL WITH. STATE
EFFORTS AND CLARIFY THE TASKS
ARE EXAMPLES OF HOW THE STATE
CAN ACHIEVE ITS GOALS. THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN KALRA
PROTECTED LEAVE DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO NARROW PROVISIONS ON
SICK LEAVE AN UNPAID LEAVE THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
NINETEEN NINETY THREE COM WATER.
UNEMPLOYMENT TRANSFER FAMILY
CARE GIVER I HSS WORKERS DO
PASS. ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR COM LONGER COMMUNITY
GRANTS FOR EMERGENCY PLANNING
DO PASSES AMENDMENT TO AS
AMENDED TO LIMIT THE NUMBER OF
GRANTS IT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY FIFTY NINE COM
LONGER CANINE TESTING HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY ONE LACKEY DNA TESTING
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY THREE LACKEY
INFORMATION CARD HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB THIRTY SIXTY NINE
LACKEY HIRING PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT LEVINE
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE
LIMON FIRE ARMS INSPECTIONS DO
PASS WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN
LIMON MODEL GUIDELINES TO PASS
ON ANY ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
FIVE OH ONE THE MON TENANT AND
BAR RELIEF TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO. REMOVE PACE PROGRAM
PROVISIONS ALLOWED TO NINE
MONTHS OF FORBEARANCE FOR
VEHICLE RELATED LOANS CLARIFY
TYPE OF CAR RELATED LOANS
ALLOW FOR ATTESTATION FOR BOTH
CAR RELATED LOAN FOR PARENTS
AND MORTGAGE FORBEARANCE AYE
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN LOW MOAN
PENALTIES FOR OIL AND GAS BILLS
TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN LOW
EXPEDITE EXPEDITED PROFESSIONAL
LICENSING DO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY LOW
PARDON PLEASE DO PASS ON A. B.
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY NINE LOW BEREAVEMENT
LEAVE TO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
MAIENSCHEIN MATERNAL HEALTH
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH TO PASS
ON TO BE ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY THREE MAYES DISEASE
RESEARCH TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE ONLY PROVIDER OUTREACH
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
ABTWENTY TWENTY TWO MCCARTY
ADVANCED PLACEMENT YET TEST FEE
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY TWO MCCARTY CALPERS
NOTIFICATIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ALLOW THE USE OF AN
EMAIL NOTIFICATIONS THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY ONE MCCARTY COLLEGE
PROGRAMS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE GENERAL FUND COST ALLOW
COLLEGES TO USE EXISTING FANS
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO
MCCARTY PAROLE DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE ONLY PEARL
RE INTEGRATION UNITS ARE
CREDITS EXCUSE ME- THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB TWO
TWENTY SIX MCCAW. WEST
SACRAMENTO FLOOD PROJECT TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
NINETEEN THIRTY MEDINA STERN
ELIGIBILITY BILL EIGHTY POLICY
OVERSIGHT DO PASSED WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING IN. AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE MULLIN
REGIONAL CLIMATE NETWORKS TO
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO MOVE
THE PROGRAM TO THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH AND REVISE
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS LIKE
IT'S OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY EIGHT OH NINE MULLIN B.
CDC REFORM TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO
MARE CG FIREARMS DEALERS DO
PASS. ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN IS THERE
IN FUNCTIONAL RECOVERY
STANDARDS HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY TWO OH THREE NAZARIAN
INSULIN COST SHARING TO PASS.
WHEN THIS ONE. WE AT THE TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY TWO NINE. SO I'M I
DID I SKIPPED A BEAT SEVEN SO
TWO MAY SAFE BECAUSE BECAUSE-
THAT GETS OUT ON ANY CALL AB
NINETEEN SEVEN IS HEARING WAS
HELD IN COMMITTEE AB TWENTY TWO
OH THREE NECESSARY AN INSULIN
COST SHARING IS A TO PASS WITH
THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE IS
THERE IN PARKINSON'S DISEASE TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
ONE OH EIGHT OBERNOLTE JUDGES
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB THIRTY
TWENTY TWO OBERNOLTE JUNIOR
HUNTING LICENCES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY FIFTY TWO
O'DONNELL INSTRUCTIONAL TIME
FLEXIBILITY DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO LIMIT THE DAYS AT SCHOOL MAY
USE FLEXIBILITY AT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROVISIONS IN
BEGINNING THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO SCHOOL YEAR THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SIX O'DONNELL SCHOOL CLOSURE
NOTIFICATIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE SURVEYED
APPLICATION THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE O'DONNELL PREVAILING
WAGES TO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL. AB THIRTY THREE THIRTY
O'DONNELL CANNABIS DO PASSES
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE CIVIL
PENALTIES THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWENTY SIXTY FOUR PATTERSON
LOCAL PLANS HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
PATTERSON HIGH SPEED RAIL
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX QUIRK DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM TO PASS. WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE QUIRK
CELL TOWERS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO MAKE CLEAR FINE AND
TECHNICAL CHANGES THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED COURT CLIMATE CHANGE
CHANGE INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING
TO PASS WITH A MOMENT TO
CLARIFY THE WORKING GROUP
PERFORMS DUTIES ONLY WHEN
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT FUNDS THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY THREE QUIRK
SILVA. A CHILD CARE ALTERNATE
PAYMENT PROGRAM TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY ONE TWELVE
RAMOS SUICIDE PREVENTION OFFICE
DO PASSES AMENDED TO MAKE THE
BILL PERMISSIVE THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. AB THIRTY
NINETY NINE RAMOS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TRIBAL
ASSISTANCE DO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB THREE SKIP ON THAT AB
TWENTY FIFTY ONE RAY S. FOSTER
SIBLING RELATIONSHIPS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN REYES INMATE HAND CREWS
DO PASS. ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX REYES
MEDI CAL BLOOD SCREENING LEADS
BLOOD. MEDI CAL BLOOD LEAD
SCREENING DO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY ONE
REYES EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT WORK GROUP DO
PASSES AMENDED TO REQUIRE A
WORKGROUP AND MAKE CONTINGENT
ON BUDGET ACTION BACK IT'S OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR REYES
REFUGEE ASSISTANCE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION AND ADD A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET. THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE THREE OF US OFFICE OF TO
END HOMELESSNESS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE USE OF
EXISTING RESOURCES. AB BACK
IT'S OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY FORTY THREE ROBERT RIVAS
CAL OSHA STANDARDS DO PASSES
AMENDED TO ADD URGENCY CLAUSE
REQUIRE NEW WORKPLACE STANDARDS
AND MODIFY GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS.
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR
ROBERT RIVAS TELEHEALTH GRANT
PROGRAM DO PASS AS AMENDED
DESTRUCTIVE GRANTS PROVISION.
THAT GETS OUT ON IN A ROLL
CALL. AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY FIVE
ROBERT RIVAS STREAMLINING
MEDIUM DENSITY HOUSING HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN RODRIGUEZ MEDICAL
INTERNS AND RESIDENTS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO CLARIFY AFFECTED
WORKERS THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN RODRIGUEZ HOSPITAL
PP STOCKPILE TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO REDUCE THE STOCKPILE TO SIX
MONTHS THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
RODRIGUEZ CAL O. E. S. DO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY FOUR RODRIGUEZ HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WORKFORCE ASSESSMENT
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE BLANCA
RUBIO SECONDHAND GOODS DO PASS
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWENTY THIRTY RUBIO I HAVE
BLANCA RUBIO CAL GRANT TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO MAKE FORMULA COST
NEUTRAL BACK IT'S HAD ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BLANCA RUBIO RUBIO CANNABIS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB THIRTY
ONE OH ONE BLANCA RUBIO INCOME
TAX CREDIT HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB NINETEEN OH SIX SALAS
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS DO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. AB NINETEEN
TWENTY THREE SALAS STUDY OF
NATURAL GAS SHUTOFF DEVICES TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN SALAS MEDI
CAL BLOOD LEAD SCREENING TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY NINE SALAS TEMPORARY
LICENSES TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY SIX FORTY TWO
SALAS LAND CONCERT CONVERSE.
CONVERSION LAND CONVERSION
INCENTIVES HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
THIRTY TWO OH FIVE SALAS
REGIONAL GRANT DO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB THREE OH TWO
SALAS EMMA YOU SPOT BILL DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN SANTIAGO
TRANSGENDER WELLNESS IN EQUITY
FUND DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
STRIKE THE APPROPRIATION. THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY THREE
SANTIAGO OFFICE OF IMMIGRANT
REFUGEE AFFAIRS HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED SANTIAGO HOUSING DO
PASSES MENDED MAKE IT SUBJECT
TO AN ANNUAL BUDGET
APPROPRIATION THAT GETS OUT ON
A. B. ROLL CALL. AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN SMITH EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TEAM TO PASS AS
AMENDED INCLUDE SCHOOL HEALTH
IN AN AREA ADDRESSED BY THE
TEAM THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. AB THIRTY TO THIRTY EIGHT
SMITH CALPERS PILOT PROGRAM
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE STONE JUVENILE
POLICE RECORDS TO PASS ON A B.
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY STONE FALSE CLAIMS ACT
TO PASS O A B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY SIX NINETEEN STONE
COASTAL RESOURCES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE STONE CANNABIS TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY EIGHTEEN UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY WERE REPORT DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REDUCE WORKLOAD
BURDENS ON THE STATE
COMPTROLLER THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN TEAM CAL FRESH TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY THREE TEEN SHELTER CRISIS
PROGRAM TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE VOEPEL
VETERANS MENTAL HEALTH STUDY DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY SIX WALDRON DRUG
TREATMENT REPORT TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FIVE WEBER LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY TWO WEBER JABALI FOR
CRIME VICTIMS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE
WEBER REPARATIONS TASK FORCE TO
PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. ACA
FIVE WEBER GOVERNMENT
PREFERENCES IT DO YOU PASS ON A
B. ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FOUR OF
SIX WICKS ONLINE RENTAL
REGISTRY HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR WAY X.
DEBT SETTLEMENT COMPANIES TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REMOVE FEE
CAP SECONDS OUT ON B. ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY SIX
WICKS ADVISED FUNDS DO PASS ON
A B. ROLL CALL. AB THIRTY
NINETY TWO WHICH SEXUAL ASSAULT
STATUE LIMITATIONS DO PASSED
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WOULD MEDI
CAL PHARMACY BENEFITS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO STRIKE THE
PROHIBITION OF RECRUITMENT.
MODIFY DISEASE MANAGEMENT
PAYMENTS REINSTATE DEFINITION
OF SPECIALTY DRUGS AND
AUTHORIZE INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT
SECONDS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY SEVEN WOULD
HEALTH INSURANCE SUBSIDIES
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETEEN WOULD ADVANCE
PAYMENTS DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ADD SAFEGUARDS
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR WOULD
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
REPORTING TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE CORNER REPORTING AND
REQUIRE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES REPORT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY THIRTY WOULD
HEALTHCARE PAYMENTS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CLARIFY FUNDING
PROVISIONS MAKE DATA SUBMISSION
BY. MAKE OUT ITS MISSION
VOLUNTARY REQUIRE REPORTS AND
SPECIFY CONSIDERATIONS FOR DATA
RELEASED THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY- ROM THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
PESTICIDE POISONING DO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. AB THIRTY THREE
SIXTY EIGHT THE COMMITTEE ON
JOBS ECONOMY AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT SMALL BUSINESSES DO
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY FIVE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION CREEK
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES DO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. I WANT TO GO
BACK TO JUST ONE OF THE BILLS
THAT WE- STATED AS A DO PASSAGE
TO DO PASS AS AMENDED AB THIRTY
TWO TWENTY SIX BY MR MCCARTY
THE WEST SACRAMENTO FLOOD
PLAIN. ARE FLOOD PROJECT IT'S
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO DELETE
THE PROVISIONS THAT AUTHORIZED
THE STATE TO PROVIDE FUNDING.
ABSENT FEDERAL FUNDING AND
ALLOW OTHER PROJECTS TO BE
FUNDED. THE DPA IT WAS AT A
ROLL CALL WE DEALT WITH THAT WE
CAN DEFINE. YEAH I WAS JUST A.
BUT OTHERWISE IT WAS CRAP. WITH
SUSPENSE. DUMP JUST FOR THE
SUSPEND STOP YES WE STILL NEED
TO DO AS SENATE BILL IS. THAT
MISTER BRADFORD IS NOT HERE. IT.
BOB A SOMEWHAT. APPARENTLY
MISTER BRADFORD DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT WE DO WHEN SENATORS DON'T
SHOW UP. WHERE CAN GIVE MISTER
BRADFORD FIVE MINUTES. SO WE'LL
JUST TAKE A QUICK BREAK INTO A.
ALL RIGHT SINCE I'M CENTER
BRADFORD DOES NOT FEEL LIKE
JOINING US TO PRESENT HIS BILL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON AS A
CO AUTHOR IS SO KIND TO PRESENT
SB. SIX TWENTY FIVE. DO E HAVE
EIGHTEEN T. WITH US. WE HAVE AN
OPERATOR. THIS PART HERE OKAY
GREAT HI WHAT'S YOUR NAME. AB
AT AMY SORRY AB. OTHER AMY. IS
YEAH OKAY ALL RIGHT SORRY WE
HAVE ECHO IN HERE SO SOMETIMES
IT'S HARD HI AMY- WE'RE GONNA
HAVE MISTER CALDERON PRESENT
THE BILL IN THE WILL GO AT TO
THE LINES IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE. IT'S CALDERON THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
WOULD PUT THE CENTRAL BASIN
MUNIZ MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT.
INTO RECEIVERSHIP BUT THE WATER
PUNISHMENT DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISS CARILLO IN A SECOND BY
MYSTERY OF US. THANK YOU
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I WROTE.
GREAT AND MISTER CALDERON ON
BEHALF MISTER BRAD FOR YOU WILL
ACCEPT AMENDMENTS CORRECT THAT
WOULD EIGHT PROVIDE PROTECTIONS
FOR CENTRAL BASIN WALK
EMPLOYEES AS A TRANSFER. FOR AS
A TRANSITION TO THE CONTROL OF
W. RG EXTEND THE WAIVER OF
LIABILITY TO THE LOS ANGELES
LAP CO AND PROVIDE LAUGHED- AN
EXTRA THREE MONTHS REPORT THE
RESULTS OF THE MUNICIPAL
SERVICE REVIEW TO THE
LEGISLATURE. YES YOU LOVE THANK
YOU FOR ACCEPTING THOSE
AMENDMENTS. WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND- I HAVE ENJOYED
THE DO PASS RECOMMENDATION DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT. ARE YOUR NEW MEDICARE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS WILLIAM CREWS AND THE
ATTORNEY FOR THIS INFORMATION
WATER ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF SB SIX ONE
FIVE WE'RE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE INTERVENE DIRECTLY
TO BRING SANITY TO THIS
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT. THE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS THIRTY
SEVEN PURVEYORS WITHIN CENTRAL
BASIN. YOU SHOULD ALSO SEE
LETTERS OF SUPPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES SO THE
CITY'S WATER COALITION. SEVERAL
INDIVIDUAL CITIES THESE
ENTITIES COMPRISE VIRTUALLY
EVERY ENTITY THAT PROVIDES
WATER TO HOUSEHOLDS AND
BUSINESSES IN THE CENTRAL
BASIN. AND THERE'S OVERWHELMING
LOCAL SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THIS BILL WOULD PUT A QUICK
STOP TO THE DYSFUNCTION CENTRAL
BASIN WHICH HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
ADDRESS A COMPLETE AGENDA FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS. HERE WOULD TAKE
OVER NORMAL OPERATIONS RESTORE
NORMAL ORDER. AND THE BILL THEN
REQUIRES AN ORDERLY EVALUATION
THROUGH LASKO SO IT CAN OFFER
SUGGESTIONS TO YOU THE
PERMANENTLY FIX THIS PROBLEM.
THIS IS A PRUDENT RESPONSE TO
THIS SITUATION. AS THE STAFF
ANNOUNCES POINTS OUT THERE'S NO
COST TO THE STATE TO DO THIS.
GENERATION HAS NORMAL REVENUE
SOURCES AND ENOUGH WIZARDS TO
OPERATE ONCE THE RECEIVER
RESTORES ORDER. ACT THE
RECEIVER WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE
THE STEPS NECESSARY TO
STABILIZE REVENUE SOURCES AND
SAVE EXPENSES BY NEGOTIATING
FAIR SETTLEMENTS TO THE MANY
PENDING LAWSUITS. AND DEALING
PROPERLY WITH OTHER FISCAL
ISSUES. IN TESTIMONY BY THE
OPPOSITION AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE WE HEARD
SPEAKERS CLAIM THAT THIS BILL
IS SOME EFFORT TO PRIVATIZE
PRIVATIZED THE AGENCY. THAT IS
NOT TRUE NO ONE IS SUGGESTING
THAT THE AGENCY BE SOLD TO
PRIVATE INTERESTS OR THAT BE
OPERATED AS ANYTHING OTHER THAN
A PUBLIC AGENCY. RECEIVER
ITSELF AS A PUBLIC AGENCY AS A
MET MEMBER AGENCIES CENTER
MASON MUST REMAIN A PUBLIC
ENTITY IT IS NOW AND IT WILL
STILL BE A MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT AFTER THIS BILL
PASSES. WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE SPEAKERS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT WITH THEIR NAME
AN ORGANIZATION- ON THE PHONES
AMY. YES OUR FIRST I WILL COME
FROM ONE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN ONE TWENTY THREE. ELLEN
SHANAHAN PRESIDENT NASTY LOCAL
NINETEEN NO TWO ONE REGISTER
SUPPORT AND THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS AGAIN FOR LOOKING OUT
FOR THE EMPLOYEES OF CENTRAL
BASEBALL OR DISTRICT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND OUR
NEXT QUESTION OUR NEXT CON-
COME FROM ONE ARE NINETY THREE
LINE AND NINETY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MONNING WELL WHAT THE
RESIDENTS OF CITY OF DOWNEY I
SUPPORT SB SIX TWENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WELCOME
LINE. THIRTY ONE LINE THIRTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. COPELAND
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF SIGNAL
HILL I SUPPORT SB SIX TWENTY
FIVE AND ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT FIND WILL
COME FROM TOO CUTE TO. TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
NAME IS ANDREW LARA AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF PEOPLE WALK WATER
DISTRICT- WITHIN THE CONFINES
OF CENTRAL BASIN I SUPPORT SIX
OF BILLS I'M SORRY I SUPPORT
SENATE BILL SIX TWO FIVE. WE
REALLY NEED YOUR HELP WE NEED
GOOD DIRECTION AND WATER THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND THE NEXT
FINAL COME FROM TWO HUNDRED AND.
TWENTY SIX TWO TWO SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JENNIFER CUCHILLO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA WATER FIFTY
ATION SUPPORT. THANK YOU LIKE
FINE WILL BE SIXTY SEVEN SIX
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK HELD THEM LIBERTY
UTILITIES- SUPPORTING THIS SB
SIX TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU X.
VOCAL TIMELINE OF SEVENTY SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN NINE IS OPEN. YES
MY NAME IS ANDREW HAMILTON I'M
AN EMPLOYEE AT CENTRAL BASIN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT THE
FINANCE DIRECTOR AND ALSO THE
TREASURE. AND I HOLES WOULD
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AS AMENDED. Q. THANK YOU.
LIKE FINE LAW THIRTY FIVE THREE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ON A WHEEL CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JOHN ONSCREEN I AM A
CURRENT MEMBER OF THE CENTRAL
BASINS BOARD OF DIRECTORS I'M
IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE. AND IHEARD YOUR
YES VOTE THANK YOU. YOU ARE
NEXT. LINE WILL COME FROM TWO
TO FOUR TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON BACK MEANWHILE WHILE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL OUR
COMPANY. ABOUT. THANK YOU NEXT
FINAL BE FROM SIXTY EIGHT SIX
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
IS GIL LEVER CITY MANAGER CITY
OF DOWNEY. ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF DOWNEY WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. NECKLINE WILL
BE FROM MUCH. TO TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MICHAEL GOLD
HEARING THE HARBOUR HEIGHTS
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT GENERAL
MANAGER. WE SUPPORT SB. SIX TWO
FIVE. NECKLINE WILL BE SOME
SIXTY FIVE SIX FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MANY MEMBERS WOULD
MAKE A TIME THERE THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION MY NAME
IS FERNANDO DO TRY THE CHAIR OF
THE SOUTHEAST WATER COALITION
BOARD WHICH IS A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY COMPRISED OF ELECTED
OFFICIALS FROM EACH OF THE-
ELEVEN THIRTY IS COMMERCE TO
READ OF SOUNDING LIKE BOB. HERE
ABOUT LEAGUE OF PICO RIVERA
SANTA FE SPRINGS SOUTHGATE
BERNARD AND FIVE WITH ANY A WIN
HERE WHILE ALSO COUNCIL MEMBERS
WHO SHALL BE WATER COALITION IS
IT ALL SUPPORT AND THAT'S
BASICALLY FIVE THOUSAND THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR
NEXT LINE WILL BE FROM FORTY
SEVEN FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YES CAN BRADBURY MARBLE AND
WATER COMPANY IN SUPPORT. I
NEXT TIME WILL BE FROM ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN ONE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS A JOGGING
GARCIA I'M A RESIDENT OF
NORWALK AND I'M- ORDER SB. SIX
TWENTY FIVE. OUR NEXT FINAL ONE
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
BLANKA TACKLE MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF DOWNEY OUT WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I MUCH. IF
YOU CONNECT FINAL FOUR OF ONE
FIFTY FOUR FIVE FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS JOHN
MORENO ON THE CITY MANAGER FOR
THE CITY OF PARAMOUNT AND
PARAMOUNT IS IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. NEXT A BORDERLINE OF
ONE TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY DOCTOR. BOB ON THE
BORDER. THANK YOU. AND I CLIMB
WILL BE FROM FORTY NINE FOUR
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BY NUMBER DON'T OF THE CITY OF
CLAREMONT I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TWENTY THANK YOU. AND THE NEXT
WILL FORM SEVENTY FOUR SEVEN
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS SHERIN CAMARA I AM AN
EMPLOYEE OF THANK WILL BE TOO
MANY PEOPLE WALKING A DISTRICT
FOR THE PAST THIRTEEN YEARS.
BUCKLEY I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE SENATE FOR PROTECTING THE
EMPLOYEES AND I THINK THE FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU. AND OUR
NEXT FIND WILL BE TWO FORTY SIX
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI ANGEL WENT
INTO MY JOB AND I THOUGHT BOY
THE BILL AS AMENDED. THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT PLAN WILL BE FROM. TWO
FORTY SEVEN TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES I AM- LOOKING DOLLARS A
RESIDENTS CITY IT DOWN AND I
ALSO SUPPORT THE BILL. OUR NEXT
FINAL COME FROM ONE OH FIVE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CONNECTING YOU MANY
MCCAMLY HURLEY HIGH WATER
RESOURCES MANAGER AND YOUR
DEPARTMENT MANAGER POSITIONS
WILL BE COMMUNICABLE WATER
DISTRICT. AND I AND ALL THE
SUPPORT SB SIX TWENTY FIVE AND
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE-
SENATOR FOR ARE WORKING TO
INCLUDE THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU. AND I CLIMB
WILL COME FROM TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE. TWO SIX FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO I JUST
WANTED TO CALL IN TO- TO TELL
MY POSITION ON AC A FINE AND I
WANTED TO SAY I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. OKAY I JUST WANNA
REMIND PEOPLE ON THE LINE THE
ONLY PUBLIC TESTIMONY WE ARE
TAKING IS ON SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
AGAIN THAT'S SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
BY SENATOR BRADFORD. EVERY
OTHER BILL IN THIS COMMITTEE IS
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE NOW SO
WHATEVER POSITION YOU HAD ON IT
OR HAVE ON IT YOU YOU CAN.
CONTACT SOMEBODY ELSE BUT IT'S
NOT OF RELEVANCE TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND WE'RE NOT TAKING
TESTIMONY ON IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CAN I NECKLINE WILL
COME FROM TWENTY SEVEN TO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO BUT-
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU YOU ARE MY
THE CAMANCHE RODRIGUEZ AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE SIX TWENTY
FIVE. IF YOU KNOW NEXT PLAN IS
ONE THIRTY FIVE ONE THREE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH THESE
ROLE IN- AYE OPPOSED TO SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE. I DON'T AGREE WITH
ALL THE MAYORS OF THE CITIES
NOT FOR THEIR OWN BENEFIT NOT
FOR THE TOPIC. THANK YOU
CONNECT MY WILL COME FROM ONE
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
ARMENDARIZ CHRISTIAN I'M ALSO A
RESIDENT OF DONNIE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. YEAH SENATE MAY NOT
GET THAT. YEAH THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. THANK
YOU PLEASE. I THOUGHT SO TOO.
WITHOUT IT I'M SORRY I. NOT
SURE IF YOU SAW WHAT YEAH OUR
NEXT ONE WILL BE FROM ONE FIFTY
SEVEN ONE FIVE SEVEN PLEASE
THAT. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME THE ROCKETS ON FROM
CUTTING HAY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU AND LINE
SEVENTY FIVE SEVEN FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME'S ERIC
RODRIGUEZ RESIDENTS FROM VALUE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NOW ONE FROM.
ONE SEVEN SEVEN ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
ONE SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M ON THE LINE I'M A
WITNESS I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING TO ME I DON'T HAVE A
NUMBER. ARE ARE YOU WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. YEAH OKAY LET'S GO
AHEAD AND TAKE YOUR TESTIMONY
AS A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION I
THINK THEM THINGS GOT CONFUSED
BECAUSE I HEARD SOME OPPOSITION
ALREADY BUT WE WILL YOU CAN.
START YOUR TWO MINUTES NOW.
OKAY ARE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TO KEEP
YOU HAVE ACTED WILL TURN. I
CURRENTLY SERVE AS THE CHAIR OF
THE FACTUAL BASIS AND I NEED A
FORMER MEMBER- AND THE CITY
COUNCIL LOCALLY AND- I MAY AND
EIGHT TO THE HONORABLE MEMBER
NINE LEE I CURRENTLY. TEACH IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM-
WE'RE NOT HERE TODAY BECAUSE
CENTRAL BASIN IS DELIVERING
DIRTY WATER. WE'RE NOT HERE
TODAY ESPECIALLY FROM HAVE
STOCK DELIVERING WATER TO OVER
TWO MILLION PEOPLE. AND WE'RE
ALSO NOT HERE TODAY BECAUSE
THERE ARE MANY MISSING OR
THROWING MONEY AT CENTRAL BASE
AND- WE'RE HERE BECAUSE A SMALL
GROUP OFWEALTHY RIGHT AGAIN
TRIP WANTED PEOPLE TO OUR WATER
SYSTEM. ACTIVE ALMOST ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ASSETS JUST LIKE THE GUYS. IN
OUR NEIGHBORING CITIES. SO
THERE BILL IN HALF AN HOUR THIS
IS BASED ON BY AND I URGE. THAT
YOU SAY NO TO SENATE BILL SIX
TWENTY FIVE. THE FACTS ARE THAT
CANCEL BASEMENT FISCALLY
SOLVENT. DUMPED INTO THE THING
HAVE HEEDED. YEAH IT'S STILL.
GOING TO BE BOMBARDED STANDING.
I'M I'M REALLY CONCERNED THAT
KIDS ARE THE- HAD SO MANY
MISREPRESENTATION. THAT
INDIVIDUAL BACK AND ENTITIES
SUCH AS THE LA COUNTY BORDER
SUPERVISORS REPORTERS. YES THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
HAVE NOT CHARACTER RESOLUTION
IN SUPPORT. OF YOUR BILL-
MAKES. REFERENCES TO A TWENTY
THREE. RD BUT ALL ALL. OF
FAILED HELLO YOU THERE. WILL BE
IN. ALL OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE. AND IT
ALSO. TO TELL YOU THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN. FIVE QUESTION. OR
COMPLETE. AND NOT THE ONE FOR
THOSE ISSUES AT PLAY SIMPLE
HERE IS THAT THEY'LL GIVE THEM
DOWN A DIFFERENT BROWN. BROWN
ARE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR EVEN
THE BOW OF OVER TO ME CITIZENS
FACTREPLICA IN AN EFFORT A
SMALL GROUP OF THREE WRITING
AND- WHO STOLEN GET FIFTY OVER
IN PARTS ARE NEEDED PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEM FOR PROFIT OUR
VERY YEARS HAVE NOT BEEN A
WEIGH IN ON THIS. WE ASK YOU
ALLOW BACK THEY HAVE WE ARE.
OUR COMMUNITY ARE IN THE
DISTRICT SO THAT THE CAN BE
PLAYED A NO SENATE BILL SIX ONE
FIVE THANK YOU WATER EXPERT
THAT IS TO MINUTES YOU WANT
LITTLE BIT BEYOND TO MAKE SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TO. IT'S ARE
IN NEED WE HAVE ANY OTHER ON
THE LINE ONE IS RED THEIR OP.
TO ASK. SIX TWENTY FIVE. AB WE
ALSO HAVE OUR ATTORNEY WHO I'M
SORRY I'M SO YOUR TEST IS DONE
WE NEED A NOW GO TO ANY OTHER
COLOR AND OFFICE YEAH SO I WILL.
THE A WAY IN THIS BY. IS
ANTHONY WILL BE. IN YOUR AND
OPPOSED THANK YOU FOR BREAK
ATTORNEY. OKAY WHAT WE ALLOW
TWO MINUTES FOR OPPOSITION IN
THIS. IN THIS COMMITTEE TWO
MINUTES FOR SUPPORT TO MISS
PROPOSITION AND THEN JUST
SIMPLY REGISTERING YOUR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION SO WE'VE ALLOWED
FOR OVER TWO MINUTES NOW OF
OPPOSITION. AND WILL MOVE ON TO
ANY OTHER PHONE CALLS THAT ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO STATE THEIR
OPINION. YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
YOU MY PERSONAL ONE ZERO NOW.
NO VOTE A LINE OF FORTY ONE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
HELLO YEAH OF THE BALL MY NAME
IS WHEN THE BAPTIST I'M
RESIDENTS OF LAKE ROAD AND
MEMBER I LASTED THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERAL COMING TODAY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. A THAT BACK
IN THE MA'AM WELL THAT MEANS
THAT THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE ARE TO A- ALL WE ARE TAKE AS
SOME. NAME AND THEIR
ORGANIZATION OF THEIR WITH WINE
AND THEIR POSITION. THANK YOU.
I UNDERSTAND MY POSITION NOW.
THANK YOU. AND NECKLINE WILL
COME FROM ONE AT TWENTY ONE TWO
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT WOULD BAN
ON ARTS AND THEN I A- CURRENT
EMPLOYEE OF CENTRAL BUSINESS
FOR WATER DISTRICT OF TWENTY
ONE YEARS AND I SUPPORT WITH
AMENDMENT AND THANK YOU TO THE
SENATORS. THE WORKING TO
PROTECT THE EMPLOYEES OF
CENTRAL BASIN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND THE NEXT ONE WILL BE.
TWO SEVENTY THREE TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS DIRECT LINE BE I'M THE
ACCOUNTING MANAGER OF CENTRAL
BASIN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT.
I'M CALLING INTO SALMON FULL
SUPPORT THAT SB SIX TWO FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOUNG. AND NECKLINE IS ONE
TWENTY NINE ONE TWO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. RICARDO ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTY SEVEN ALL UP
HOLD DON'T GO TO DEMAND. THANK
YOU. AND OUR NEXT ONE WILL COME
FROM AT TWO THIRTEEN TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH MY NAME IS
RICHARD BEARD BRUCE I'M A
CONSTITUENT IN THE CENTRAL
BASIN AREA I WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT THE LAST NIGHT THEY
ALL RAN TO YOU I'M SORRY. I'M
SORRY WE'RE ONLY WE'RE NOT
TAKING TESTIMONY I'M SORRY SIR
YOU CAN EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ONLY. I OPPOSE
RECALL THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
ON A CRIME WEALTHY FROM. NINE
TO SEVENTY FOUR TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO RECOUP ROBBER ONE BY ONE
HERE IN FELT THE CALIFORNIA.
AND I AM FEELING I'M
DISENFRANCHISES FROM THE- THERE
SHOULD THANK YOU SIR. WE ARE
ONLY TAKING. YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE
THANK THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU IF
YOU CAN DISCONNECT THE PHONE. I
WANNA BE REALLY CARE WHERE THE
POINT OF TESTIMONY NOW WHERE WE
CAN ONLY ACCEPT YOUR NAME AND
YOUR POSITION IN EITHER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION ALTHOUGH
WE'RE NOT. WILL IT WILL TAKE
THAT BUT WE CAN WE- TELL TIME
ALLOWS TODAY WELL THAT'S ALL
THIS COMMITTEE ALLOWS IN ITS
RULES. AND OUR NEXT LINE WILL
COME FROM TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE TWO TO ONE YOUR LINE
OF. MY NAME IS MONEY ESPERANZA
I'M FROM. HE SOUTHEAST AREA
AND I AM ON THE I'M NOT A
MEMBER OF THE ALLEY COUNTY
CENTER COUNTY COMMITTEE I'M
ALSO ON THE BOARD OF THE NATIVE
WOMEN'S UNITY ASSOCIATION I AM
ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF BLUE LACK
THE RECYCLING. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND TING TALE
TO THE FRONT TRAIN KO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND OUR NEXT
LINE WILL BE ONE FIFTY ONE ONE
FIVE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
HI MY NAME TWENTY NINE CHECK BY
MY CONSTITUENTS OF SOUTHEAST
CONFRONTED WITH I LOVE CLEAN
WATER AND FOR THAT REASON I
OPPOSE SB SIX TWO FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I NEXT FIND
WILL COME I'M NOT TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY TWO TWO ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS CARMEN
GONZALEZ I EVEN THE CITY OF
BATTLE ON MY STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
SIXTY FIVE WATER BE THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE'RE NOT TAKING
TESTIMONY TODAY WERE JUST
TAKING YOUR POSITION THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TIME I COME FROM TWO
FORTY NINE HUNDRED FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS MARCUS
LEAVE RIGHT NOW SO RESIDENCIA
BELL AND I'LL POST. TWENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. AND THE NEXT FINAL
COME FROM TWO THIRTY THREE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME'S
KRISTINA MONTH ALTHOUGH I
RESIDE IN THE CITY OF SOUTH
GATE I STRONGLY OPPOSE SIX TWO
FIVE. WE NEED FAIRNESS NOT
JUDGE FROM THANK YOU. AND ARE
NOT CONFINED WILL COME FROM TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE TO
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
BARRAULT I AM A RESIDENT OF THE
CITY OF BULKY. MY FAMILY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AND YOU ALL
SHOULD BE ASHAMED THANK OUR
BANKING L. WE'RE JUST TAKING
YOUR YOUR POSITION THANK YOU.
NEXT FINAL COME FROM EIGHTY
EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WOULD THAT BE ME YES. OKAY MY
NAME IS FERNANDO CHECK ON IT
RESTARTING THE CITY OF
MONTEBELLO I'M ALSO
COMMISSIONER FOR THE MON VALLEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
STRONGLY OF COLD SB SIX TO
PARK. THANK YOU. X. BY LOCAL TO
ONE TEN ONE ONE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES HELLO MY NAME IS
SELECT GROUPS AND I'M A
RESIDENT OF HUNTINGTON PARK AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
YEAH X. FINAL GOAL ONE ALL ONE
HUNDRED AND ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BOB WHEN I WON YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES MY NAME NEEDS
PARDEE OPENS UP FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALL YOU UP WITH
AN AYE STONE L. PULLED SB. SIX
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS LOPEZ. AND OUR NEXT LINE
WILL COME FROM TO NINETEEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HI MY
NAME IS BARBARA AND I LOVE LOW
WHO. FIVE BOB THAT. THANK YOU.
AND THE NEXT ONE WILL BE FOR
ONE OF FORTY ONE. HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MONDAY MOVEMENT THE GEORGIAN OF
FROM THE CITY OF MEN WITH AND I
STRONGLY ABOUT. THANK YOU. AND
RECORDED THE NECKLINE OF FIFTY
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS ARE ARE GOING
ON THE DIRECTOR WAS CENTER
BASED IN I STRONGLY OPPOSED. SB
SIX TWENTY FIVE THE CALDERON
GRIP. THANK YOU. NECKLINE WITH
TWO FORTY ONE TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS MARGARET
HAD A I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
SUCH A BASED ON WHAT THE
SITUATION. A PASS APPOINTED
DIRECTOR FOR THE CENTRAL BASIN
MISS WATER DISTRICT MANAGER A
MANAGER FOR PEOPLE ARE DISTRICT
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE
BILL SIX TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
AND I FIVE WILL GO TO FORTY
THREE. OR DO YOU HAVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AFTERNOON THAT THE
PAINT YOU WILLIAM FOURTEEN YEAR
EMPLOYEE OF CENTRAL BEING SPENT
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
SENATOR LOCAL POINTING-
ARTISTRY AND HONEST WILL
SUPPORT AT THE SIX TWO FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK THE
NEXT LINE OF ONE. ONE THIRTY
FOUR ONE THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES THE NAME IS JOSEPHINE
FLORES GARCIA. I AM A RESIDENT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS CORPORATE
TAKEOVER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND OUR NEXT FIND COME FROM ONE
TWENTY NINE ONE TWO NINE.
RICARDO DISTRICT FIFTY EIGHT
I'LL PROBABLY DON'T GOVERNMENT.
YOU ANNEX FINAL COME FROM TWO
NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS CHARLIE HAD A
CAT ON THE FORMER CITY MANAGER
THE CITY OF SIGNAL HILL AND I
LIVE WITHIN THE CENTRAL BASE OF
SERVICE AREA AND I'M CALLING TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB. SIX
TWENTY. YEAH YEAH. AND THE NEXT
ONE WILL COME FROM NINETY ONE
NINE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH CONCEAL
AND I'M A RESIDENT OF LAKE
WOULD AND ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
LA COUNTY CENTRAL COMMITTEE AND
A CANDIDATE FOR STATE SENATE OF
THE THIRTY THIRD DISTRICT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIXTY FIVE
THANK YOU. AND THE NEXT FIVE
WILL COME FROM A FEW HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE TWO EIGHT FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SHAME ON YOU
RIGHT EIGHT. YEAH I THINK YOU
AN UNLIKELY ALLY WILL COME FROM
TWO FORTY FOUR TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS THE THIS IS A FRANCHISE
I'M A CONSTITUENT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IT I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SIX TWENTY BINDING KIA. NEXT
ONE WILL BE FROM AYE TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT TWO SIX
EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
YES MY NAME IS ANGELA TRAVELING
OUTSIDE IN THE LEXUS AND THE
NEGLECT A MEMBER OF THE CENTRAL
COMMITTEE. OF THAT LUFTHANSA
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
SECRETARY OF LUCK WITH A ONE
HUNDRED AND NINE STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SIX TWO FIVE. THANK
YOU. THE NEXT ONE WILL BE TWO
EIGHTY NINE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY- BROTHER I'M ALSO AN ELECTED
LA COUNTY CENTER COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND ALSO CENTER BASED IN
REPAIR I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
SIX TWO FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MEXICO TO THE LINE TO
NINETY TWO TWO HUNDRED NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT IT
WAS BIGGER ROLES IS ALWAYS
PRESIDENT OF THE PEOPLE WATER
DISTRICT IN PICO RIVERA AND ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUES AND THE
STAFF OF THE PEOPLE WATER
DISTRICT ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT. OF THE SENATE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
RECORD TO SHOW THIRTY NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS A CLIMAX FROM THE CITY
OF LAKEWOOD CITY AND YOUR-
ASKING YOUR I'D GO TO ON SB
SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU. YOU THE
NEXT ONE WILL BE FROM ONE
TWENTY NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY.
RICARDO DISTRICT FIFTY EIGHT
AYE OPPOSED DON'T GO TO DEMAND.
YEAH OUR NEXT LINE WILL COME
FROM TWO FIFTY THREE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS KELLY
KIND OF CLUB AND THE DIRECTOR
OF PUBLIC WORKS FOR THE CITY OF
SIGNAL HILL AND I SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY ARE SENATE
BILL SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ALRIGHT FINE COME
FROM TWO HUNDRED AND. NINETY
FIVE TWO NINE FIVE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS MOTION
UNDER WATER SKI AND I IN THE
YOU FOR COULD NOT HEAR AND I IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWENTY FIVE.
OKAY YOU. AND OUR NEXT FIND
WILL COME FROM THREE HUNDRED.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS MICHAEL HERE I'M
CALLING ON AS A RESIDENT OF THE
CITY OF LIQUID AND I'M CALLING
IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWO
FIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
MY NUMBER THREE OH Q. THREE
HUNDRED INTO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS CAROLYN- RUBIO
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND- I
JUST WANNA LET YOU KNOW THAT-
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM CANNOT HEAR
YOU AND ABOUT THE ROUTE THAT
YOU ARE ON YOUR PHONE- AND I
HOPE. I'M SORRY WE'RE JUST
TAKING SUPPORT OR OPPOSE I AM
SORRY I HOPE PEOPLE CAN HEAR
AND FOR THOSE WHO CAN'T EYES
PART. MEANT PHONE SERVICE.
THANK YOU YOUR INPUT. I'D LOVE
TO DO THIS SOME OTHER WAY BUT
THANK YOU. THE NEXT FINAL COME
FROM ONE TWENTY NINE ONE TWO
NINE IT MYSELF BUT. ONE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEP
AUTO DISTRICT IF YOU AYE
OPPOSED SIX TWO FIVE DON'T GO
TO THE MAN. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER. COMMENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CALDERON I THINK WE'RE THRILLED
THANK YOU AMY FOR BEING A
FANTASTIC OPERATOR- I JUST WANT
TO COME BACK TO SOME OF THINGS
WERE SAID JUST TO BE CLEAR WE
ARE NOT VOTING TO PRIVATIZE A
PUBLIC WATER AGENCY IS THAT
TRUE MISTER CALDERON. DISTRICT
INTO RECEIVERSHIP OR THAT THE
GOALS OF THAT THE DISTRICT CAN
FUNCTION PROPERLY SO THAT THE
RESIDENTS IN THE AREA CAN GET
THE PROPER. RESOURCES THAT THEY
NEED THAT SHOULD BE FOR
PROVIDING BEING PROVIDED BY
THIS WATER AGENCY- WE PLACE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
RECEIVERSHIP- AND THERE'S NEVER
AN ATTEMPT- TO PRIVATIZE. OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SO THIS IS
A WHAT WAS IT THE WAY TO KEEP
THIS IN PUBLIC HANDS NOT TO
PRIVATIZE SO JUST. ANY CONCERNS
ABOUT THE PRIVATIZATION IS JUST
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN AND IT JUST
AS IN THE FACE OF. WE DO NOT
HAVE A MAN WHEN IT. SHIPS FOR
ANY OTHER LOCAL. THANK YOU I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING HOME
UNDERSTAND ON THE ACTIONS THAT
WERE TAKINGWE ALSO WHAT I
THINK YOU FOR ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS IT'LL ENSURE THAT
THE WORKERS- ARE NOT PUT IN A
IN A IN A WORSE POSITION AS A
RESULT EXACTION- WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. BUT
GLASSMAN ABOUT HALF OF THE
RAPPERS. THANK YOU THAT BILL
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL I WANNA
THINK THE ENTIRE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FOR
THIS VERY LONG. AND I DO WANT
TO TELL THOSE FOLKS AT HOME WHO
ARE WONDERING THAT WAS QUESTION
AT THE END. YES A LOT OF US ARE
ON OUR PHONES OUR COMPUTERS-
BUT THE- NUMBER OF. OUR OF
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE GETTING
IN REAL TIME COMES UP ON THOSE
DEVICES I DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO
THINK WE'RE NOT PAYING
ATTENTION WE'RE TRYING TO
FOLLOW ALONG. TRY TO DO OUR- I
AM AN EXCUSE THE ENTIRE THE
STATE FOR. PUBLIC COMMENT WE
REALLY SAY THAT SOUTH THANK YOU
FOR PARTICIPATING.